- [Instructor] The goal of this video
is to understand how median
per capita income after taxes
has trended in the United States
in comparison to some other
countries over a 30-year period.
And the 30-year period for this
chart is from 1980 to 2010.
For example, in this first comparison,
the United States is
compared against Canada,
and you can see at the
beginning of this time period,
the median per capita income after taxes
in the United States was
higher than that of Canada,
but then over the course
of this 30-year period,
it looks like they've gotten
pretty close to each other.
So you could say that the
rate of increase in Canada
over that period has been
higher for this group,
and so that's what got them to parity.
In Norway, we're looking over
that same time period again,
from 1980 to 2010, and we're seeing
a similar story in Norway.
There was actually a fairly large gap
between the median per
capita incomes after taxes
between the two countries in
1980, and that gap has closed.
Now on one level, you might say,
hey, the rate of increase
of median per capita income
after taxes in Norway is greater,
but on another level, you could say,
well, even at the end point,
someone making that median
per capita income after taxes
in the United States
will still be better off
even at the end of our
time period, at 2010.
And we see that generally true
for all of these countries.
They all have steeper curves,
so a higher rate of change,
but the United States,
on an absolute level,
has stayed higher, although
the gap has gotten smaller
for most of these.
So you could interpret it either way,
but it's probably leading
to other questions.
You might say, all right, this is just
for those folks in that 50th percentile,
the people in the middle,
the median per capita income.
What about people at other
points in the distribution?
What we just saw is for the median year,
and you can see the U.S. curve
in this burgundy type color,
and then, instead of showing
the median over and over again
over that time period, it
just plots the other countries
right over here, so you
can see trend in Canada.
At the beginning of the period,
the median per capita income
after taxes was lower than
that in the United States,
and then it closes the gap.
And then we can see the
other countries, Norway,
Netherlands, Britain,
Sweden, so on and so forth.
And this is useful, because you can see,
even though the rate of
improvement is deeper
for these other countries,
at least for the median,
you're still better off
being in the United States.
But the picture does change
a little bit depending on
which countries you look at
and which extreme you look at.
You can see that for
that fifth percentile,
there are countries like Germany,
where if you're in that fifth percentile,
you were better off in 1980 and in 2010,
relative to the United States,
but the rate of improvement
is actually similar,
and I'm speaking in very rough terms,
to that of the United States.
And then you have countries
like Ireland where,
at the beginning of the period,
you would've been worse off if you were
in the fifth percentile being in Ireland,
and at the end of the period,
it looks like you were
slightly better off.
And then, we can see that
trend for the 10th percentile,
20th percentile, so on and so forth,
and the benefit of being
in the United States
over that time period, and the improvement
in inflation-adjusted
after tax income over time,
seems to be more dramatic
in the United States
as you get to the higher percentiles.
When you see this 95th percentile,
the United States was already better off
than everyone else in
1980, and the gap between
those 95th percentiles has only increased.
Now there's several takeaways
that you could have from this.
One is that the rate of improvement
in some of these other
countries is steeper,
but on the other hand, for example,
if we look at Ireland or Spain,
the rate of improvement is steeper,
especially for some of
the lower percentiles,
but folks still have finished
up at an absolute lower level.
So even in 2010, you'd be better off
being in the United States.
Another question that some
of you might be asking
is why do you see this
phenomenon in the United States
that the rate of growth
in inflation-adjusted
after tax income over
time seems to be highest
for the upper income folks
in the United States.
It could be because of tax policy.
The U.S. does have, relative
to many of these countries,
a lower effective highest
marginal tax rate.
So for the people in the highest incomes,
they're paying a lower
percentage of their taxes
than people in other countries,
even though many of them might
be paying a higher percentage
relative to some of the
other income brackets.
You could also say that it
might not be a fair comparison.
The United States has
a much larger economy
than most of these countries.
The only ones that come even close
to the United States out
of these would be Germany,
but their economies are still
less than one-fourth the
size of the United States.
Now there could be other dynamics at play
that we talk about in other videos,
but it's at least interesting to know
what the data tells us.